well let's let's pull this story up here
i've got it here from the new york post
biden advisor liberal world order
demands enduring high gas prices i just
want to point out first and foremost
they said that it was going to be a
quick thing the gas prices were going up
now they're saying it's going to be
years yeah so uh okay sounds like that's
just the case they're saying until
ukraine wins and they might not and if
russia wins then your gas price is just
gonna stay up forever but here's the
best part about this liberal world order
thing it's not a conspiracy theory
anymore now like you said just a moment
ago they're arguing it's not the same
thing as the conspiracy theory yo
there was a time
not even that long ago couple like
decades ago if you said the the gulf of
tonkin incident was a false flag you
were a conspiracy theorist and i think
it was the 2000s when they finally came
out with reports being like actually the
u.s kind of staged the whole thing so we
could enter vietnam it's like okay
in my lifetime i have watched the
narrative break down and start crumbling
and
i mean kind of hilariously alex jones
being proven right more and more often
although he does say rather crazy and
outlandish things
he ends up talking about things epstein
that was a conspiracy theory
elaine maxwell was sentenced to 20 years
for aiding the trafficking with epstein
powerful global elites were flying on
his plane not a conspiracy theory
anymore the the line on that i thought
that was the best act and ted cruz
actually posted it ted cruz beam right
it was uh
glenn maxwell the first person to be
convicted of trafficking children to no
one exactly but there was a period where
if you brought that up that there were
powerful global elites trafficking
children they were like oh here we go
right they still try and claim the idea
as a conspiracy and if and if you well i
mean it was a conspiracy but a a fake
one like made up if you come out now but
not epstein epstein no that wasn't big
that was real i i'm saying they claim
it's not real right oh yeah like so
here's my point epstein was conspiring
with other people there was graphic
women there was a period
where you know probably only several
years ago if you claimed there was a
powerful global elite
with world leaders flying on planes and
they were trafficking they called you a
conspiracy theorist then epstein it all
comes out gulen max will get sentenced
epscene
is shuffled loose the mortal coil as it
were
now it's just like oh yeah we knew they
were doing that now the crazy thing is
there was a story i saw and it said you
know like 50 percent of republicans
believe global elites are running child
trafficking rings and it was like
incredulous and i'm like what what's
wrong with the other 50
no no but but right but the issue is
it's like they're trying to make it seem
like it's a crazy idea to have when
elaine maxwell was literally on trial at
that point let me show you this other
story take a look at this one
i just i saw this in the morning and and
you know look i normally i like the
daily mail they're not that bad they're
not like the best
clarence thomas cites debunked claim
that covet vaccines are created with
cells of aborted children in descent on
scotus decision there is so much wrong
with this story
okay
they go on to say
clarence thomas suggested covet vaccines
are developed using cells of aborted
children true
underneath that sentence it says
cells obtained from elective abortions
decades ago were used in testing during
the coveted vaccine development process
what how can you have these two
sentences next to each other they're
stupid
read the headline here's the best part
you're right you don't read you only
read the headline you don't know the
facts let's say you actually got to the
second part you're like oh clarence
thomas was right
no
clarence thomas didn't actually cite
this at all
clarence thomas thomas
referenced the plaintiff argument
in his dissent
he did not say personally i clarence
thomas believe that this vaccine is
developed with he said the plaintiffs
are suing because the vaccines x y and z
and then the media went oh he's saying
it's true too and it's like no no he was
citing their arguments which is exactly
what shu just did to aoc that's right
the exact same thing here's the best
part
the vaccines are developed
using cells from aborted babies
for the testing process i wouldn't call
that the best part but the difference
i mean i mean i don't know
is the fact that they said it's a
debunked claim
no it isn't this here says that
that they were created with the cells
but you're saying they were tested on it
with the cells but then it did the final
product
because there's the which is
possible
hold on we'll get as literal as possible
in the process of creating this vaccine
there are numerous steps now that's a
good argument the creation is the entire
process of development which requires
testing before any kind of so if you're
just talking about the final thing that
they end up making maybe all the things
they tested aren't being used in the
final things now that's a challenging
not only did he never say the words
created with he said development and he
was citing he was quoting a group they
attribute it to him they changed the
word in the framing and it's fake anyway
because
how could you create a medication
without testing it
how would you know it did anything if
you didn't test it you know you should
ask like
you're not listen you're not legally
allowed to do that imagine you were like
this person is sick i'm going to take a
chemical the chemical is medicine for it
i've never tested it but i'm just going
to sell it now no no there's a testing
process in the creation of any drug so
even if you want to get technical
clarence thomas would have been right
should he have actually claimed it was
created using these things it is just
such a mishmash garbage nonsense media
landscape anyway my point is to go back
to the liberal world order stuff
today
if you talked about new world order even
a month ago they were like it's a
conspiracy it's not real and then you
got who was it who came out i mean joe
biden said it several times he's right
so biden has said it and we were playing
the clip earlier today where he was this
is 2017 he uses the exact same phrase
liberal world order and so you you've
heard also a phrase a lot lately the
rules-based world order but when you
hear this again liberal world order and
you realize that okay this is really
it's it's
defined world by the way because it
doesn't seem like most of the world is
in this do you see build back better all
over the place
all over everywhere
but you look at the countries that are
involved with the bank for international
settlements which is the swiss bank
governs like the federal reserve and all
these other federal these banks you see
the countries that are stuck inside of
this liberal economic order it's the
same what i'm saying is you see like
maybe you know maybe japan south korea
but it's not it's not all of asia it's
certainly not all of africa um there are
huge swaths of south america that aren't
part of this thing and so when it comes
down to it you know if you can define
can we get a map of the liberal world
order you know can we get you know do we
have flags for it uh
here's what they do have a month for it
there will be someone who says
lizard people
and then they'll find the craziest claim
and say this is what the new world order
conspiracy theory believes
then you'll get a major politician like
biden saying it's time we get a new
world order and what he's saying is we
have a liberal world order and we need a
new kind of world order which means
powerful global elites and interests are
colluding for the sake of international
governance which is literally what the
council on foreign relations calls it
and then if you say oh did you see that
they're talking about new world order
and look
that means you believe in lizard people
try to debunk it before the internet it
was easy to do because the media would
just lie right now we can talk to each
other much more easily and they can't do
anything about it however i checked the
wikipedia for the
liberal economic order the
liberal rules-based order the u.s led
world economy basically and they have
wikipedia has changed the wikipedia uh
in the last month maybe even damage
control for when this guy came out and
said it they took away the throw when
you go to the wayback machine and look
at the difference it's pretty stark in
the beginning of this they were very
overt that it was a us-led world
economic reporter
yeah let's go back let's find out when
they recently changed it because they
took the us-led part out of it because
you know people are hitting it they're
reading the first paragraph and they're
toning out
but this is very much that after world
war ii they decided we don't want
another world war we're going to use the
us and the u.s military to set up
military bases all across the world
use opec the they're going to use the
american military mike to force people
to buy oil and us dollars create a
global currency create a global
authority that's basically what this
uh world order is now there's also a
world of thought that um that it's
actually sort of an inheritance of the
british empire
that where you know and maybe even 500
years from now
when
you know whatever america is at that
point or whatever you know north america
is at that point um that we may that
historians in the future may even just
consider this order as a continuation of
the british empire may not even separate
them which really was like the banking
empire that got into july by the way
like hey check it out check it out just
real quick sorry again no problem
the first article is the liberal
international economic order and then it
actually references
the new international economic order so
it's like so it's the liberal world
order the new world order the remix yeah
i think what happened was when the
rothschild family and like the 1700s
started their banking empire this
bavarian banker his three sons uh split
up and each took a piece of of the
banking empire basically that's how they
got it started one of the bankers went
to england and that guy started
controlling england through the bank and
uh that's the new world order is the
banking part of it right what so when
you're saying it's an extension of the
british empire the american empire which
is really an extension of the banking
empire this bavarian banking empire now
they're set up in switzerland uh with
this bank for international settlements
which needs way more media attention
we're gonna have to not a conspiracy
theory anymore gentlemen
the the narratives busted apart and it
was easy when someone would
you could be a researcher and you can go
hey new york times did you notice that
there's a bunch of documents showing
that there's a bunch of international
elites coming together for some kind of
global economic order and they'll say
don't know don't care we won't publish
it
now you can actually publish documents
and there's no denying it
it just breaks through the barriers your
name is julian assange there's the song
well he did a lot more than that i was
told like the un was basically all the
countries of the world the best powers
of the world and then i found out about
the non-aligned movement you guys
familiar with the non-aligned movement
it's every other country that's not in
the u.n it's basically another u.n it's
the other one like there's two worlds
going on right now i mean one of them is
the us-led rules-based economy and then
there's everything else the there's the
g7 and there's bricks and bricks has i
think what like four or five times no
like six or seven times as many people
and that's gross brix is growing so um
this is one of the biggest things that
we've seen this week and and really
nobody's talking about it that which it
and it is and i'm just gonna just gonna
say it right this is growing as a
response to the liberal world order
slipping and and collapsing in upon
itself um you can look at potentially
the turnover of hong kong as one of the
early you know kind of precursors of
this and then really though just what
two years so today right xi jinping went
to hong kong for the first time since
the protests in 2019 and those protests
were over okay so hong kong yeah they
changed flags in 97 that's when when the
uk formally rescinded sovereignty but it
was 2019 when they passed what they
called the national security law where
the ccp essentially came in and just
just took essential total control just
total control and xi jinping today this
very day visited for the first time and
he said hong kong has risen from the
ashes wow that's what he stated today
because he knows he's one so let's talk
about the list so and so no no but
that's my point that bricks is a rising
bricks is on the way up iran just stated
that they uh put in a submission to join
bricks i don't know if they've changed
the acronym then um and do people know
what bricks is argentina's talking about
it
um so brexit what is it brazil
russia
india
china south africa right five of the
world's biggest countries and certainly
population wise and they are raising a
star it's starting military but excuse
me starting economic but they're talking
they're talking military certainly china
russia uh and they're moving to ian's
point in a currency basis as well i'm
wondering about the liberal economic
order and the value of it because i i
trash it a lot the whole idea of a
global military economic government is
that's in the shadows is terrifying but
the reason it was built was to prevent a
world war now if we completely just
dispense with it it's gone tomorrow
you've got bricks you've got like an
autocratic communist government so is it
it's like is it do you believe it's one
or the other jack like what i'm
interested in your take on the liberal
economic order the value of it well so
this is me the right this gets to me as
as a populist you know and what i
believe is that i think that we do need
to go back to a system where and this is
where the phrase america first comes
from right
so people get the mistake that america
first means american only or that
america should just go and do do
whatever they feel like and that no
that's not necessarily true it's just
that our government should exist for the
benefit of the people who live within
the confines of the country right
which is the opposite obviously of what
brian d said today and so it is it is in
the benefit obviously of the united
states to have military alliances to
have trade to have economic relations
but we shouldn't put those global
organizations and transnational
organizations ahead of the interest of
our own people we need to go back to
what you know might even be considered
more of a of a 19th century type of
formulation in this idea of sure we can
have these these forums that exist right
you can call it whatever you want you
know but we should never become
subservient to them it should always be
a forum which is subservient to the
sovereignty of the nation itself i feel
like a lot of people are begging for
that kind of world though yeah right now
it's scary like when i was in new york
people were they really wanted a big
government across the whole world to
keep them safe
from covet and we just and that's the
opposite of what we've seen absolutely
and that's the by the way and that's the
great reset right that's that's what the
great reset is that's what the
documentary we're working on is about
that's apparently why i got detained in
davos for you know having the the
audacity to just simply go there and
talk about it we also went to geneva and
talked about the world health
organizations pandemic treaty that
they're trying to push on the 104 to 94
nations and so this is the problem right
the problem is that you have for example
uh i just mentioned hong kong right so
when we were in davos um
we were going up and down the promenade
we went through a huge so russia's been
kicked out right ukraine everywhere
everything's ukraine ukraine flags
ukraine house underwritten by victor
pinchuk who's victor pinchuk by the way
he was the oligarch who at one point was
one of the top donors to the clinton
foundation right so one of the most
powerful oligarchs within uh within the
ukraine sphere um russia has been kicked
out ukraine's everywhere and we're told
you have to support ukraine because you
support democracy and we also we went to
ukraine as well and um
we went down to odessa and nicolai my
brother was with me and
the one thing though the one word that i
didn't hear anywhere
at the world economic forum in davos
there was no house for it there was no
speaker who mentioned it there was no
breakout session on it and that was the
word taiwan the word taiwan was
completely omitted from the world
economic forum and so my question was
was you guys care some you know so much
about democracy and freedom
where's taiwan on this and it's simple
because the ccp has set up a situation
where they're in this military slash
economic alliance with russia and the
brics nations but they're also in an
economic relationship with the west and
the liberal world order because why
because we've been financing them with
western capital since the 1970s
essentially since the death of mao and
the rise of
deng xiaoping
and
post um
you know post tiananmen square it was it
was the bush family and it was uh so
many interests associated there to say
essentially look we're not going to push
over the power of the ccp we're going to
make a deal with you and snowcroft goes
over there and has the secret meeting
right because the ccp could have been on
their last legs if we just pulled the
rug out from under him and cut fdi
immediately on june 5th 1989 but that's
not what bush did when he was in office
he said we're going to make a deal we're
going to make a deal with you our
manufacturing is going to come over here
we're going to use your slave labor
that's where that's going to go we keep
the ip right so we get to maintain
the companies we get to maintain the
power and the profits from it you guys
get all the manufacturing and that's
been the bulwark of this liberal world
order because we've outsourced our
manufacturing to asia we've outsourced
our energy to the middle east as it was
and this was something that trump when
he was in office was whether he meant to
or not right uh that was what he was
working to roll back that's what gave us
american energy not just independence
but dominance and that was why he was so
opposed to nafta tpp so many of these
deals thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you